okay it is time for this week's hatred
mail quick reminder about what hatred
mail is so what if the president's been
accused of sexual harassment 15 times or
that he paid hush money to a porn star
at least he never wore a tan suit
patriot mail
written by Patriots who hate David
Pakman because America and because
freedom new term new vocabulary term
hatred hate realloc term that maybe it
would be well-suited for an urban
dictionary definition introduced by this
week's hatred mail let's take a listen
to it together David Pakman is a Jewish
supremacy
why don't you along with the rest of the
online Clarion's talk about what really
matters with of the leveraging of money
to deep for you just like it is for
Trump or are you afraid of losing your
show by pissing of the bankers back
behind everything whether with you or
Trump yeah I might lose the show not if
I piss off the bankers but if I piss of
the bankers and of course the hatred
mail bingo where there is supreme Thomas
tie am a supreme Thomas very very
different thing than a supremacist
Jewish supremacist which is it's a
really strange thing actually involving
a bowling ball but we'll probably have
to save that for the bonus show send a
middle finger salute to the hatred by
using the coupon code Patriot 40 H 80 RI
o T 4-0 if you apply that coupon code to
any membership on our website whether
it's six dollars a month or 480 dollars
for the year or anything in between the
coupon code Patriot 40 saves you 40% and
it really infuriates the hatreds to
learn that their hate reott ISM is only
bolstering financial support for the
show so I recommend you take advantage
of that sooner than later